eu já vi
e aí
e por favor queria que levantasse a mão
quem aqui já teve que se mudar de sua
casa ou do seu apartamento alguma vez na
vida
e porque é que só acontece né
e se no futuro se mudar não for a regra
for essa ação
é assim que eu aprender andar meu pai
começou a que levar para as obras com
ele
e eu lembro de me sentir todo importante
quando minha mãe me vestia a roupa igual
à dele que dia que eu tava indo
trabalhar
e aos quatro anos quando as crianças da
habilidade da vão desenhando carros e
monstro eu só queria saber de rabiscar
em meus projetos para o meu pai criticar
e esse estímulo me levou para a
faculdade de engenharia depois faculdade
de arquitetura
oi e para sua segunda fernandes que a
incorporadora da nossa família pertence
a minha meu pai é meu tio
e acabou virando uma tradição de família
levar as crianças para obra e quem mais
gosta dessa programação é ele meu pai tá
aqui presente
e assim mas são natural no setor alguns
um pouco mais minha percepção
a observar a forma que as pessoas se
relacionavam com os imóveis
e isso me levou uma conclusão bastante
óbvia mais inquietante imóveis eram
imóveis estáticos cheio de limitações e
restrições muitas vezes um elefante
branco
e eu ficava pensando será que é minhas
filhas no futuro não tem alguma outra
opção eu vou ter que submeter a gerações
dos imóveis
e vai caso eu sou o filho mais velho à
medida que as minhas duas irmãs foram
nascendo a gente teve que ser mudando
assim como vocês e busca de mais espaço
e eu me lembro mesmo ainda criança o
transtorno que era
já vendeu o nosso imóvel encontrar o
outro no preço condições característica
localização que a gente desejava não é
fácil para ver que é por isso que existe
aquela frase pense muito bem antes de
comprar um imóvel é uma decisão muito
importante na verdade é uma grande dor
de cabeça
e até que aos 12 anos meus pais
decidiram comprar um apartamento
definitivo
a extensão da sua palavra ter finitivo o
lugar grande de uma de gente nunca mais
precisaria se mudar em busca de mais
espaço bom
e também na época meus avós estavam se
mudando numa casa grande e definitiva
teoricamente definitiva para um
apartamento menor porque os filhos
cresceram eram oito a casa ficou cheia
de espaço que não precisava mais ser
utilizado então para que ter despesa e
trabalho mantendo aquela área
e a casa não era definitiva nada é
ou será que só acontece na minha família
é o lugar mais desejado mais cobiçado de
moradia da nossa cidade aqui de recife
avenida boa viagem está cheio de
apartamento definitivo se a gente olhar
para esses prédios à noite a gente vai
ver boa parte das luzes apagadas com a
luzinha lá no final na suíte do casal
esse casal tem uma situação aos vezes
parecida quando meus avós filho já
casaram já saíram de casa e eles
continuam mantendo uma área tendo
despesas com energia com manutenção com
limpeza bateno área que eles não
precisam mais e uma área super desejada
que poderia servir de moradia para
outras famílias
e essas áreas se torna horas mortas
dentro de um organismo vivo que a cidade
é
bom e como não podemos utilizar para
outras famílias a gente acaba
construindo mais prédio
bom e com isso a gente vai aumentando a
distância entre as pessoas e o trabalho
melhorando a mobilidade gerando mais
poluição
a oitenta por cento das emissões de co2
são causadas pelos prédios que geram 5,7
milhões de toneladas de resíduos todos
os anos mas ele não são vilão aí os
prédios acomodam o crescimento da
população e hoje no mundo metade das
pessoas já vive na cidade então se nós
precisamos deles para acomodar o
crescimento da espécie humana porque não
otimizar todo o espaço que ele
proporciona ao máximo
e partindo dessa questão seul na coreia
do sul iniciou uma secretaria de
compartilhamento para mapear famílias
cujos filhos já saíram de casa para que
aqueles quartos vazios pudessem ser
reutilizado tem alguma forma perceber um
estudante de intercâmbio você colocado
na web e assim reduzir ou evitar a
necessidade de construção de novos
espaços
e ainda não das limitações dos imóveis
quem já viveu o que conhece alguém
próximo que se divorciou sabe o desgaste
e o sofrimento que gera dividir o imóvel
o imóvel não se dividir isso gera
bastante transtorno ou na situação já
desgastada o mesmo acontece com heranças
irmãos que acabam se desentendendo para
dividir o que não se divide imóveis são
imóveis
e nos últimos anos o brasil atravessou
ainda vem atravessando uma crise muito
forte e só distratos e execuções
houveram mais de 20 bilhões de reagir
o que deixou várias famílias em suas
casas
e isso não acontece só aqui
oi gente voltar um pouquinho dos estados
unidos em 2008 a crise do subprime fez
os bancos tomarem as casas dos
americanos por falta de pagamento
e deixando as americanas também sem casa
e do outro lado tentavam revender esses
imóveis e não conseguiram mercado tava
parado
é bom mas é o país mais rico do mundo
vão resolver essa situação dez anos
depois não tem uma solução os imóveis
continuam imóveis
oi e o setor é o culpado disso
em uma pesquisa recente a publicação
recente da universidade de harvard
mostrou que só existem duas indústrias -
inovadores do que o setor da construção
civil indústria da caça e da pesca
bom e com a chegada dos milênios hoje
era são super conectada a deve tomar com
o nome de compartilhamento que não quer
mais saber de comprar um imóvel só que
ele tem o acesso do imóvel aí é que foi
ficando cada vez mais difícil imaginar
como é que ficaria o futuro dessa
relação entre as pessoas e os imóveis
e como é que ficaria esse abismo entre o
contemporâneo eo comportamento
contemporâneo e as práticas arcaicas do
setor
e aquilo me incomodava profundamente a
culpa na nossa afinal nós é que fazia
dos imóveis
e o gente aceitava que a gente precisava
fazer alguma coisa ou iremos continuar
fazendo que as pessoas sofrerem com
todas as limitações
bom então para tentar mudar esse jogo ou
pelo menos fazer a minha parte minúscula
diante de um setor que movimenta mais de
2 trilhões de dólares ao ano
e eu resolvi investir em inovação
fazendo cursos que pudessem abrir a
minha visão
e para que a gente pudesse encontrar uma
forma dessas limitações para além de
atormentar a vida das pessoas
bom e foi no curso dos martírios
normativo cidades inteligente que eu
conheci a reinvenção da automóvel
proposta de revisão automóvel a partir
de questionamentos simples no indústria
tron tradicional mas com poder de
transformação enorme então pensei puxa
porque eu não posso aplicar essa
metodologia para o mercado imobiliário
que é onde eu nasci e cresci conheço um
pouco dessas dores
o ocidente menta na época nós estávamos
construído o edifício que foi o primeiro
5 suítes aqui do estado apartamento que
custavam já mais de 3 milhões de reais e
quando a crise chegou a gente
simplesmente parou de vender e não tinha
nada que nós pudesse eu vou fazer para
reduzir o imóvel para dividir o imóvel
para fazer alguma forma cabelo do bolso
das pessoas
e foi aí que tudo ficou claro a gente
não podia mais ficar refém de uma oferta
estática uma demanda que a dinâmica
e a solução para isso foi buscar na
tecnologia uma evolução do conceito de
projetar e ao invés de projetar
apartamentos imóveis
e nós agora estamos fazendo módulos
residenciais e inteligente
o ou seja módulos capazes de se combinar
ou se diz combinar para que possam ser
aumentados ou diminuídos ao longo da
vida e assim possa acompanhar as
mudanças de necessidade de espaço ou de
bolso das pessoas ao longo da vida
e aí essa tecnologia demos o nome de
malévola' habitações resiliente os
primeiros lançamentos com essa nova
tecnologia apesar de terem sido feito no
auge da crise por um sucesso e gerou uma
repercussão por todo o país essa
repercussão iniciou uma jornada mais
humana da arquitetura e da engenharia
voltada para resolver e atender a
necessidade das pessoas
é mas nós temos um problema na verdade
vários problemas
a fazer um empreendimento resiliente
exige alinhamento de inúmeras técnicas e
fazer tudo isso manualmente elevou o
custo de produção o custo de elaboração
de um projeto de arquitetura em mais de
dez vezes a saída para isso
eu vou recorrer a uma inteligência
e para que pudesse alinhar esses
alimentos e viabilizar todas aquelas
possibilidades a inteligência artificial
bom e com ela
é uma nuvem
o rodrigo em qualquer parte do mundo
empreendedores e arquitetos pudessem
acessar o nosso sistema e se tornar
multiplicadores da resiliência
resolvendo esse problema que afeta a
vida das pessoas em qualquer parte do
mundo tem hora que a mente
é mais apesar de termos tido uma solução
que teoricamente seria perfeita fizemos
um uma solução exponencial de um alcance
para todos todas as partes que poderiam
ser afetados por esse problema através
de uma rede global de colaboração todos
os arquitetos poderiam usar o seu
conhecimento suas expertises prato é
qual aquele projeto a funcionalidade
estética e cultura que é única em cada
lugar
é mas será que o mundo também sofria que
eu te problemas será que isso faria
sentido em outros países
e vai responder essa pergunta eu comecei
a conversar com pessoas de quatro
continentes diferentes empresas pessoas
apresentando o conceito ouvir os seus
anseios as dificuldades que eles tinham
em relação aos imóveis
e em dois anos foram 376 incorporadoras
distribuídas em 11 países diferentes e
cheguei numa conclusão onde tive a gente
e onde tiver imóvel a resiliência é a
grande saída para as cidades e para
melhorar a vida das pessoas
e nós temos agora a condição de não
produzir mais áreas mortas nos
organismos vivos da cidade e porque não
fazer um compartilhamento como lá de ceo
em qualquer parte de maneira
profissional sustentável e escala global
e esse é o futuro das cidades e das
habitações mas o mais importante o
impacto positivo disso na vida das
pessoas
o imagine quantos divórcios podem ser
amenizadas quanto sofrimento quanto
desgaste se os cônjuges dividirem seus
módulos cada um ficar com seu não
precisa ter briga para dividir baixo
o imagine aquela velha frase de eu quero
deixar a minha herança toda resolvida
que eu não quero briga dos meus filhos
quando não tiver mais aqui agora isso é
possível cada herdeiro pode ter o seu
próprio módulo isso pode ser feito em
vida inclusive
ó e todo sofrimento daquelas famílias
que perderam suas casas e que iriam
perder mas agora com essa solução elas
podem devolver apenas os módulos que não
podem pagar
é mas não é só solução de problemas
existe um componente importante nessa
equação que a qualidade de vida e o que
é qualidade de vida para mim acho que
para muitos é
e é poder passar mais tempo com quem a
gente ama
bom e com essa nova modalidade as
famílias e os amigos podem morar no
mesmo prédio cada um e quantos modos a
sua fase de vida de mandar
e se nós não podemos
e parar o tempo porque não multiplicar
os momentos
o quanto vale a liberdade ea
tranquilidade desse casal pais e mães
que podem curtir um sábado à noite
sabendo que seus filhos pegaram o
elevador e subiram foram dormir na casa
dos avós em
não existe um estudo da universidade de
stanford que mostra que a voz que
convivem com os dentro
e aumenta o solo atividade tem mais
motivação para viver
né e acabou se movimentando baixo no dia
a dia esse mesmo estudo mostra que
possua veja crianças que convivem com
seus avós
e crescem menos ansiosos mais confiante
e com caráter mais sólido
eu vejo uma força do que nós estamos
falando aqui se trata de vender imóvel
e nós estamos criando condições de
formar pessoas melhores esse é o futuro
e o melhor ele já começou muito obrigado
e aí